i think he's become  i'd say notably unhinged  in recent times i think this invasion  is not the actions of a sane man  interested in the welfare of his country  so i do i do think he really is  getting unhinged now  before he was only evil and mean now  he's also evil mean and unhinged it's a  bad combination  he's a narcissist  a psychopath  with no conscience whatsoever  and  he's an egylomaniac  he is  his death an egonomaniac with very  strong paranoid tendencies in other  words he has a mania of grandeurs  and the maniac persecution  the persecution is in large part  assumed i think and pretended  it's supposed that he's adopting  i think the the the mania of grandeur is  absolutely real and deep and profound  that i can testify from from a very  variety of indices